[Music]
yeah what's going on everybody it's lord
matcha here from lords of gaming.net i'm
here with thomas talking about falconer
his latest debut game
how you doing today i'm good i'm good
i'm enjoying it good good so tell us a
little about falconer
is an open world air combat fantasy game
so
a lot of people a little bit older like
myself like freelancer
or you know crimson skies and i had
someone on the internet saying it's like
what would happen if gandalf flew into
mordor on the eagles and had lasers
so they'll give you a taste it's a
you're basically a guy mounted a giant
falcon and you've got ranged weapons and
you're sent out to do battle against
other falconers but also fantastical
creatures
dragons airships that don't a lot
basically
perfect perfect but what i understand
about falconer is that it was
developed untraditionally can you
explain a little bit about the
development process about the game
uh well i'm developing it by myself
so i've been around game stream for a
long time and it's one of those
narratives where
i really wanted to do something by
myself and i had trouble
grounding with big teams and lots of
stress so i ended up making this and it
really
connected and i found the right people
to help me out the publisher wired
so it's a solo game with lots of
experience
it's got a rather quirky art style i i
use very minimal art when then very
detailed
atmospheric effects for instance i don't
use any textures so people dig into that
or they don't
uh speaking of that i mean but that art
style itself is beautiful
so i wonder if you could break down a
little bit about what our what the
player is going on here like
because i can see we have different kind
of atmosphere yeah and there's different
time of day as well so you can explain a
little bit about what's going on
so that's an active day night cycle he's
flying around
in the world uh i don't know which
mission he's at probably doing the basic
mission
or the tutorial he's flying around and
what you do is you
when you're flying you have to gain some
energy and then the blue bar at the
bottom not hit things with your seven
the blue bar will go up and you can use
the blue bar with the b button
to do acrobatics uh yeah like barrel
rolls which is super
handy in combat it allows you to do
things which you can't do with an
airplane that makes the game a little
bit different from
other flying games you can really you
know throw that bird around it's it's
really uh
in that sense it's a it's a different
type of game what are the kind of
inspiration behind
the falconer because i'm seeing a little
bit of old-school kind of
uh zero dragoon or something like that
well a lot of people come with a
pencil dragoon but i think that was a
sega we didn't have a sega when i grew
up
we had a pc uh so uh i grew up on you
know
the first on elite only elite like the
first one
in europe we had amiga consoles um
and a tie fighter if anybody remembers
that by lucasart which was a great which
is a flying game at its core with all
the you know battleships coming in and
you know the interdictors warp yeah it's
intense hyperspacing it's not starting
so i really enjoyed that type of
gameplay and uh
i think a lot of if you think back to
the game stream for me that flying
feeling is sort of a
good archetypal game experience flying
man it's just flying around someone
talking what to do i thought i want to
make a flying game
and because i don't want to make like a
walking simulator in the sky
i had to do combat so there's lots of
combat in there lots of
engagement and agency for it's not just
about discovering the open world but
you know you got to protect it or
destroy it
beautiful beautiful so tell us a little
bit about the music though um
what kind of what kind of music can
players expect to hear as they're flying
around
well the music does by benedict nichols
which is a great uh
composer uh and we're trying to so
we're trying to use lots of different
instruments so there's a little bit of
throat singing
then in there which is this mongolian or
even northern europe
type of back of the vocal cords type
string
which works great if you combine it with
electronic and you know a little bit of
electronic music
so it's going to be fairly freaky music
but then again we have
when you hit the imperial locations
which is much more industrial airship
there's more like bagpipes even and the
briefing was i don't want
anything that is like your typical fancy
farewell
oh god but you know this fantasy
choir stuff so it's all a little bit you
know more hardcore
and uh moody music i like it perfect
uh well i did see that the game does
have a photo mode
so yeah we gotta get the hashtag hashtag
falcon your photo mode once the game
drops
absolutely absolutely i made the photo
mode for myself to make screenshots and
then
wow it's not a lot of effort to make
this more polished and enjoyable
and it's a fun thing you use the left
stick and right stick to
rotate camera or zoom in uh
turn the daylight with uh some of the
buttons so you can change tonight and
take beautiful pictures i think that's
fun
you know i love that you could actually
change the time of the day too
yeah well it's it's it's i think that
there's a school where you can say well
that would interfere the gameplay
because a night mission would be a day
mission
uh i'm not that bothered because it's
fun you know and
i'm it's not a dark souls it's not a
source like it's
it's gonna be i i like you know the
experience should be well you should be
frustrated
if that means you want to take a sunset
picture by all means do it
perfect perfect so now we talked about
falconer we got
a little into the details about it when
can players actually get their hands on
it well
at the moment we're saying 2020 so we're
not we haven't announced the date yet
uh but it's it's it's it's chugging
along uh
uh and it's it's making good time so it
won't be too long
so perfect what platforms can players uh
get out they call
an xbox first title so it's uh got uh
it's coming to microsoft xbox first
and to a pc platform so it's already
available on steam to wishlist
perfect perfect thank you so much for
your time thank you for talking about
falcon here look it's looking great and
good luck on development
we'll catch you guys next time this is
laura macho signing off
[Music]